Let's conclude with a word about
the status of predictive coding
today.
In legal systems, it's difficult
to change existing practice
because of laws reliant
on past precedent, which
causes current decisions to be
made on the basis of past ones.
Because the types of
eDiscovery admissible in court
have historically been limited
to keyword search coupled
with manual review,
nearly all cases
today use this
eDiscovery approach.
However, this status quo seems
to be starting to change.
In 2012, a US District Court
ruled that predictive coding
was a legitimate
eDiscovery tool, which
may pave the way for its
expanded use in coming years.